[Music]
since you've had kids what's the what's
the biggest thing you've had to give up
since you became a dad well i've had to
give up a lot but one of the
the craziest things that happened
uh and it really didn't apply until
actually until i was doing ted you know
i didn't miss it at all until i was
doing this movie uh was my wife was
driving with my daughter in the car
and they were out by like thousand oaks
in the country my wife and my daughter
was like mommy what's that smell and she
was like oh that's a skunk and she goes
oh daddy smells like that all the time
and my wife told me that and i was like
okay i'm not even going to call my
friends i'm just flushing it down the
toilet right because i don't want to
ever have to have that discussion but i
never missed it at all until ted which
is you know teddy is basically this pot
smoking coke sniffing
you know
hooker banging teddy bear who's a really
bad influence on me and uh you know but
uh that was that was pretty crazy well
this is in the movie uh first of all
this is seth macfarlane's first movie
yeah and uh so he's interested in in in
having you play this character you're
the boy who grows up with a teddy bear
he's your best friend he comes to life
and then uh he he ages with you and you
both become you're degenerates at times
yes so when when i first heard the pitch
i was like this is not for me but when i
read the script like 30 pages into it
you forgot about the band it's just this
great relationship yeah seth is such a
talented writer director and he also
does the voice of the bear yeah he's
very funny he's the bear and he does a
good he's he's a new england guy he does
a good boston accent yeah he does he's
uh he talks like this a little bit but
yeah yeah yeah
he's putting it on a little bit uh
you i'm just curious when you had never
seen i've heard i heard that you have
never seen family guy before they came
to you with the idea of this movie they
come to you and they say it's seth
macfarlane from family guy you had never
seen the show before read the script met
with him fell in love with him and they
said hey by the way see his show so
it's a cartoon so i'm like well let me
watch this with my kids
no i swear to god i swear to god i don't
know what's going on it's on fox i
figure it's just a cartoon right so i
sit down 150th episode which is stewie
and the dog locked in a in the bank
right he's got to go to the bathroom he
poops in the diaper he makes the dog eat
the poop then he throws up because the
dog's eating the poop then they start
drinking liquor he pulls out a gun on
the dog and all this crazy stuff my kids
are laughing hysterically right we're
having the greatest time ever and of
course my wife comes barging in because
what the hell are you doing rips the dvd
out and i was i've been on punishment
more than i know
it's like one thing after another my
kids and i we just we got a i got a
paintball gun and my sons they love it
they want to shoot the side of the house
they want to shoot the tree and they
said daddy can we shoot anybody
and i said well i'm not going to get
shot but maybe you can ask my friend big
a who's a tough guy so he goes you want
to shoot me of course i don't say no to
the kids so we shoot him like 40 times
my kids are laughing hysterically and
then my wife finds out and she takes my
paintball guy
i'm learning you're learning so she took
my paintball again
we have a clip here from ted i don't
know exactly which scene this is
this is the white trash names where ted
finally he's met a girl i forced him to
go get a job he gets a job at a
supermarket he meets a cashier and we
always have this guessing game where now
i'm gonna try to guess the girl's name
he says it's a white trash name and i
try to rattle off as many names as
possible and by the time i get the name
right he's supposed to stop me
and uh it's 57 names in total yeah this
would be a hard scene to do let's take a
look at this clip from ted
i met a girl she's a cashier no way
that's awesome yeah you know what's her
name white trash name yes
mandy no
marilyn nope
britney nope tiffany nope candace all
right speedrun i'm gonna rattle off some
names when i hit it buzz it okay we'll
tell you you got me yeah all right
brandy heather channing brianna amber
sabrina melody dakota sierra bambi
crystal samantha autumn ruby taylor tara
tammy lauren charlene chantel courtney
misty jenny christa mindy noel shelby
trina reba cassandra nikki kelsey shawna
jolie and early and claudia and savannah
casey dawley kendrick holly chloe devon
emily becky nope
wait was it any one of those names with
a lin after it yes i got you okay brady
lynn heather lynch
[Applause]